[Music]
this morning on the dish
a traditional hawaiian feast we traveled
to our 50th state for a visit with mark
naguchi a former hula dancer turned chef
naguchi's passion for hawaiian food and
culture is contagious
and he brings along a personality almost
as entertaining
as the tailgate luau
gooch yeah what's up can i call you
coochie you can call whatever you like
jeff but sure
i like gooch thanks mark naguchi met us
at a small
farm off the grid on hawaii's north
shore
no wi-fi or electric lines here just
heaps of food
and unmatched scenery i mean look at
this
yeah you saw the goats right here there
right it's unbelievable
the backyard and the your reaction is
what i try to what we try to share with
our daughters our daughters are growing
up here and i tell them
girls you got to remember that people
saved their entire life
to to come here in the way that yeah
you've traveled the world and you're
like oh my gosh yeah yeah
and it's genuine it is telling our girls
like don't forget the gift that we have
naguchi has been fascinated by food
since he was a kid
but after running into trouble as a
teenager he says it was something else
that saved him
dance from his late teens and into his
twenties naguchi was a professional
hula dancer a job that required constant
travel
where he got to meet new people and
sample more of the foods that would
eventually lead him to his next calling
cooking and sharing traditional hawaiian
cuisine
i think a lot of people come to hawaii
and they have no idea what food they're
about to get i think somebody's just
misinformation it's it's
what is hawaiian food what is hawaiian
food thanks for asking
you know it's it's uh it's my job yes
right it is your job
in hawaii we identify ourselves
ethnically
in the continental united states many
people identify themselves
geographically i'm a new yorker i'm a
los angelino
from chicago every shy town here in
hawaii
we have so many cultures right so it's
like i'm japanese
you know um joe is portuguese and i have
you know
chinese friends and i have my hawaiian
friends and so the same thing goes with
food
is when you say hawaiian food the
average person's idea of what hawaiian
food is
it's not wrong but we can dive into it a
little bit more
dive into some of the best hawaiian food
you'll ever see
and taste is exactly what we did so this
is laulau
and lao lao is taro leaves right here
that we're gonna take some fish and some
pork that we've seasoned just with salt
i'm gonna teach you how to wrap it up
i'm gonna teach you how to finish it off
this okay
all right go ahead and season this baby
nice season that we're good yeah
okay confidence love it okay so we have
a pork belly
i want you to take one of the big leaves
like this and the simplicity
of this is the fact that right if you
think about it there's tao leaf
yeah fish pork salt four ingredients
that's it that's it what more do you
need in life keep it simple right
kiss so take a couple pieces go ahead i
like to take one with plenty meat more
fat
a piece of fish like that i'm gonna take
it
one two wrap it up
next take my tea leaf nice little
nice little pouch i'll say the pod yeah
a little packet
and there is more than one way to wrap
la la
this is just this is the way i wrap it
i'm gonna tie
a single knot that's a single overhand
okay
square knot it's like a special package
delivery great
and here's the package maybe the most
important thing to understand about mark
naguchi
is this he does not chase what's
trending at the
expense of what's necessary something
the hawaiians call
pono you say pono
over popularity always what does that
mean for you
you gotta do what's right you know it's
your kuleana your responsibility to do
what's right
here in hawaii for so many of us that
are born and raised we are tied here
genealogically you know like the way
that a lot of us look at it is like
when we mess up we don't have that we
don't have the option of like oh
you know i shaved my i shamed the name
or i got myself into trouble with the
law i'm gonna move
so i think that there's that strong
sense of
doing what's right or you know living my
life with
abandon it's not an option
when we asked for a spot to set up his
dish presentation
naguchi selected the exact opposite of a
white tablecloth
this is a real tailgate it is it is this
is so local style
the presentation included dishes
prepared by naguchi
as well as some of his favorite
selections from two hawaiian
institutions
highly a family favorite for takeout and
helena's
owned by craig ketsuyoshi who's
continuing a tradition
started by his grandmother both have
been around for more than
70 years and craig kosyoshi is known for
pipicola so pipi beef cola
string and it's essentially beef jerky
that the paniolos you know they came up
with and
it was their way to preserve beef but if
you want to try it yeah
so that one right there oh yeah nice big
yeah
you got to get the fat on there you got
to get the fat you got to get that oil
also on the menu squid luau
pastel stew poi kalua pig
tarot root and salt meat watercress
stew you'll find watercress coming out
of you know the corners of most loi like
wetland
you know wetland tower fields it grows
so
you know it was this very humble almost
peasant
sort of vegetable to me this has a lot
of heritage because if you think about
it
you know when as plantation people
our local food what came about because
we had a lack of resources
and it was cultivated by the most
resourceful of people
then there's the adobo chicken pieces
marinated in soy sauce and spices
pan fried and stewed until tender now
adobo is filipino
so now you see right we have this
amalgamation we got this sort of little
party going on
of all kinds it's a good party yeah it's
a good party
it's a great party for dessert a
hawaiian
coconut pudding what do you say
refreshments what do you want your
legacy to be
oh that's easy when i die
i want my wife to say that i was a good
husband i want my children to say that i
was a great dad
and i want my community to say that mark
noguchi didn't waste space
that's all i want he's not wasting space
uh-uh
it's a ten hour flight six thousand
miles so we could not have food here
unfortunately
um and i am unabashedly a mark naguchi
fan he was
it's so easy to be a fan of his i love
that he gave
others some shots that's exactly right
that was just
such a moment for me and his piece and
he is a part of that community
he is not wasting space no way